this is the moment you've been waiting
finally met the perfect guy he's smart
in touch with his feminine side makes me
laugh I'm teaching you now but there's a
time where you're gonna have to do this
yourself lady
well you're telling me if I shave I'll
look like that yeah holy crap this is
ideal why do we have shavers study in a
second intros Greg huh please here
oh I want my Lauren I want my Lauren is
her biological birth name go check out
her channel it's a fun channel yeah mr.
nightmare is as equally fun five very
disturbing things that happen to people
while home alone is this gonna give me a
nightmare
it's not going to give you a nightmare
but it might worry you so much and you
might think about it so often that you
will attract it happening it's your life
Law of Attraction people that's how it
works you know I had a stalker show up
at my house last week I am sorry for
doing it but I promise I have really
listened to the wall lately okay alright
I just wanted a photo let's do it
ooh scary text
an 18 year old boy named Liam was home
alone for a whole week when his dad and
stepmom went on their honeymoon
while playing video games in his
brother's old bedroom well it sends me
doubt he could hear kind of scraping
noise that seemed to be coming from
outside the strange thing he seen was on
the second floor so it seemed nothing
but odd to hear something outside
scraping against the walls he tried to
ignore it by turning the video game up
louder but the scraping sounds only
became more apparent he decided to
finally look out the window but it was
too dark to really see anything
he left the window open a crack to
better hear the noise if it persisted
Liam spun around to discover the window
was now open and someone was crawling
into the room through it he was able to
push the intruder back out the window
before he could fully make it into the
room that fell two stories down into the
bushes below he apparently wasn't too
injured as he was gone within minutes I
like got scared I started yeah yeah it
was during the rainy night in Central
Islip on Long Island a teenager named
you know my Tama gone so he invited his
friend Karl over his friend texted that
you would be over two minutes
he interfered the video games he planned
on playing with Carl confused as to why
Carl went out back he went out to the
backyard his shed door was open with the
light on as he called out Carl's name
walking to the shed the light inside the
shed turned off simultaneously Ian
received a text from Carl saying I'm
here he responded are you
he responded back I'm at the front door
as he looked up the door to the shed
pulled shut with force I'm scary
expecting like Carl would when the
police responded to IANS call they
checked the shed found the door was back
open and that nobody was inside I like
this video I got chills all over now I'm
terrified morning went to go on my shed
45 year old Chris was supposed to be
working late for the night but only went
out to eat dinner without him however he
was unexpectedly able to come home early
as a result he had the house to himself
for a few hours he went down to his man
cave in the basement to watch TV that
was when he heard the backyard basement
window flop open and someone stuck their
head inside to peering around the room
he hid behind the couch until the person
shot the window Chris ran upstairs with
the baseball bat and shut off all the
lights he waited in the kitchen which
was by the back door somebody suddenly
reached thrown through the pet door in
an attempt to unlock the door Chris
swung the baseball bat as hard as he
could at the person's arm causing him to
scream and flee that same lights sirens
roared down the street and stopped at a
neighborhood house it turned out one of
Chris's neighbor's three doors down had
been murdered and when his wife came
home she found the house was ransacked
with missing valuables everywhere and
then she found her husband dead on the
kitchen floor with a stab wound in the
back of his head [ __ ] oh god it's him or
a young girl named Ann was home alone on
Friday nights
her parents were out to dinner and her
sister was out with friends she was
taking a nap on her bed
she'll walk to the thumb
she was sure it came from her closet
door so she got up and bravely opened it
there didn't seem to be anyone inside
so she closed the closet and spun around
there she saw the head under the bed the
head of the moon missed it she fell to
the floor screaming that's when the
closet doors behind her opened and
someone grabbed her and pulled her in
the man from under the bed emerged and
approached her as she was being held
down the two of them carried her
downstairs where they put tape over her
mouth and tied her arms together one
checks to make sure the coast was clear
before carrying her outside where they
climbed to put her in their car's trunk
however about halfway to their car a
large group of teenagers in writing down
on their bikes and witnessed at all some
of them were screaming for help
well some of them got off their bikes
had started to slowly approach the two
men they knew they wouldn't get away
with it now so they dropped in jumped
into their car and sped away
Wow or is completely awake and conscious
throughout all this Oh tell me why they
didn't just tie her up while she was
sleeping the most realistic
possibilities that they simply wanted to
scare the girl this may seem like a
crazy rare occurrence and you may even
call a fake however things like this
happen all the time and are shown
commonly on the news perhaps they're
just the stories we forget about
oh yeah there's one more where 2
year-old Garber still looked with his
parents he was the youngest of three so
his two siblings had already moved out
and his parents were out three to four
nights a week it's one particular stormy
night he was home alone in his room but
we could swear he heard something hit
his window
it wasn't insanely weird as the weather
was pretty bad something may have just
blown into his window however a second
cut at the window sent his heart racing
he lifted his blind I could see somebody
standing out there even through the damp
windows in the pouring rain
he knew he did not recognize that person
he shut the blinds to send a message to
go away however he wasn't even able to
move away from the window so before
something else was thrown at the window
Garber opened the blind and this tiny in
the window and shouted what he wants the
man down below called back come outside
I want to show you something
Garber went downstairs to call the
police I would ask him to feel sure that
he didn't know the person and if they
had caused any damage the 9-1-1 operator
ice carved a call back if the person
continued to harass him or showed signs
of wanting to break in seriously barber
hung up the phone
wanted to see a better view from down in
the kitchen so he opened the kitchen
blinds
Garber called the police right back and
inform them that the man was standing at
his kitchen room look at the kitchen
window the man is gone that was the last
time Garber ever saw that man
Wow mr. amer interesting scary or just
entertaining if you'd like to hear more
home alone stuff I do have a video
without any to home alone stories Oh God
mr. nightmare I got us okay before we
get into some of these stories kudos to
you on this video ma'am because I've
seen a lot of like am I gonna name any
channels but I've seen a lot of videos
where there's like Co scary stories true
stories but makes you did with the
animation and the sound editing the
writing the narration writing was really
well done
pretty funny like called the police
stacked looked in the world now he's
standing at my kitchen I think so casual
like the dude no that was a very well
done video yes
pretty [ __ ] scared it was Karen I was
totally like I wanted to watch the whole
thing it was an eight-minute video and I
didn't stop it was just like oh my god
that happened that first story of that
key like the first few stories like kids
being home
I just don't think being alone now is a
good idea yeah no one should be alone
ever ever it's not good it's not good if
you find yourself home alone right now
leave go somewhere in the public doesn't
matter is law strangers if you're young
I highly advise yeah that was really
scary I just thought about like my kid
in like that's like I don't have a kid
Oh what am I had a kid didn't like he
was in this situation the first one with
a girl being locked up the girl be oh
yeah that girl being locked up that was
the scary as if it was just a prank
maybe was like her parents I give to
scare her with the scare teacher lesson
shouldn't moved out so early and Gary
Mitchell horrible husband but that first
one would think he would like the person
crawling through the window oh my god I
would see ya as much martial arts as
I've done in my day I would pay ha
I would fail and I would throw Evers
with me in front of that person let's go
bail it's a good thing you know martial
arts yeah I would find my way out of
escaping this situation not trying to
protect a single human beings when he'd
be the guy with the baseball bat it
would kill the person to feed to the
cannibal trying to break in
what what's messed up though it was like
he didn't call the cops it said and then
his neighbor got killed I felt like um
oh they don't know at what time that
happened they don't have what happened
before after yeah that's still really
scary like I kid who have any
fortunately at baseball bat yeah but
like to think like that was most likely
the murder yeah yeah could it killed him
to life damn these near-death
experiences gosh people trying to break
in I can't leave people actually do that
stuff huh how does all the time huh yeah
have you ever broken into someone's home
yeah yeah I tried breaking into yours
recently hey it didn't start out well
I'm like surprised you showed up two
guests are here but as long as you get
that exposure for your talent yes as
long as you guys subscribe to me maybe
I'll come back after this yeah and
should I lift the restraining order
that'd be cool well maybe scary was
these doesn't sound like oh we thought
we saw a ghost but the ghost wasn't
there you know yeah like it sounds like
people actually broke into these
people's house like the first two were
just kids playing video games Tommy it
was just setting up for ian's what give
we can play next buddy
oh gosh but I love pulling like scary
pranks on people yeah I love pulling
horrible pranks on people all right
don't don't get any ideas Ryan wait
Greg whatever your name is everybody
still calls me all my friends computer
guidance I'll tell you about the worst
prank I ever pulled it wasn't a scary
prank it was scary in a way I was in
eighth grade this is when myspace
existed a friend named Brandon milk or
Hollywood Highland owns a restaurant
called spice go check it out we were in
eighth grade he went to El Salvador for
a couple months
Brandon called me from El Salvador and
said you know be funny if we told
everyone that I died and I was like
great joke we're future comedians let's
do this so I said MySpace
that fireworks went off and the home
caught on fire and everyone including
Brandon died and and no one found that
funny apparently because people don't
have a sense of humor but that was my
prank that's a scary prank on this heart
no more death if you want to scare
people
yeah make people think someone died
that's how you scare people that's the
best way to pull a prank you've made
this video officially awkward so thank
you without sex jokes
I'm Greg Alva subscribe today for the
real rejects make sure to subscribe to
mr. nightmare and while you're at the
whole subscription service thing check
out all my lord youtube.com slash I want
my Lauren Lauren Francesca's on
Instagram Twitter Facebook then takeover
say the rest musically vine snapchat
snapchat Pinterest tumblr geez tumblr
you tumble
I don't tumble tumble I don't tumble why
don't you tell the hall I try to keep
away from you know putting myself out
there too much okay you know I don't
want people to know my real name
what's your kick my kick you kick what's
a kick like the messenger kick
I could use it one time but that's a
different story anyway Laurens gonna
shave my back